hello we are going to get started
because it is exactly 11:10 and there
are a lot of slides so I'm super excited
to be here talking to you today about
Angelina Ballerina and memory allocation
I'm gonna start by telling you a little
bit about myself which I usually don't
do but did you know that it's like
really hard to weave in a little bit
about yourself while talking about
memory allocation and garbage collection
who knew so I live just outside of
Washington DC most people probably think
that my life is a lot of this and this
and this but actually just outside of DC
is Takoma Park which was rich was
recently ranked the eighth most liberal
town in America and is often referred to
as hippie Haven it's even an official
nuclear-free City I also have a
two-year-old named Evan who came last
year but isn't here this year devin
loves talking about garbage collection
as I was preparing for this talk every
time garbage collection came up it was a
very very exciting he would look for the
garbage trucks I would try to understand
another complex algorithm it's nice that
we both have this shared excitement over
garbage collection and whatever that
happens to me and for each of us I also
work as a developer at collective idea
it's a software consultancy based in
Michigan collective idea is a really fun
place to work because we deal with all
sorts of clients everything from fortune
50 companies to small startups just
getting going to internal products and
we work in a variety of languages which
is awesome and if you're interested in
learning more or working with us please
come find me during the conference so
for a project a collective idea we were
working on an application that involved
generating enormous Excel spreadsheets
like hundreds of rows and columns
multiple worksheets just really pretty
big the rest of the application was
actually pretty simple but this
spreadsheet generation was the core of
what the site needed to do so we're
chugging along or building this
application optimizing queries here and
there is a concern for speed and then
one day we're testing some functionality
and everything just goes sort of bonkers
we're getting every we're getting errors
everywhere our web server usage graph
had read like all those little colored
boxes that you don't want to see and so
this kicked off a whole team
investigation into what was going on and
how to solve it part of solving it was
through understanding it so I've
probably are to use some terms and
phrases that you might not know and you
might be thinking maybe I should leave
the room I don't even know for speaking
the same language nice for you I've been
to conference talks before and read lots
of blog posts that have words like heap
and malloc and all these resources that
just felt like incomprehensible words
being thrown in my way so today we're
going to go over some definitions and
scenarios and we'll dive into each of
these concepts to understand them better
and then we'll talk about some tools
that we used in order to help figure out
what was going on
how to put these tools in place mostly
related to Ruby code bases and finally
we're going to do this through Angelina
Ballerina and dance more broadly how
many people here know who Angelina
Ballerina is alright that's a good
number
Angelina Ballerina was a book that I
read a lot when I was a kid I was a
ballerina back in the day how many folks
here are dancers ok good small handful
cool so Angelina loves to dance and in
this book she dances all the time day
and night because she's so focused on
dancing she forgets to do everything
else she forgets to clean her room she
forgets to get to school on time and so
on her parents do not know what to do
so they finally decide to enroll her in
ballet school and once they do that
she's so focused on dance while she's
there and she's still focused on getting
back to ballet school that she's able to
accomplish all of these other tasks that
she needs to and of course she becomes a
famous ballerina so obviously there are
tons of parallels about memory
allocation partitioning memory focusing
and shaping memory into structures and
formats that make the program or
Angelina as productive as possible there
are also similarities between dance and
learning about memory allocation aspects
about remembering steps understanding
what's going on knowing that counts what
steps fit etc the real goal here is to
walk away with a better understanding of
what each of these pieces terms and
words that I discovered through that
process are and a better understanding
of the tools that you can utilize to
look into memory related components of
your application more effectively and
I'm really gonna try to help this
understanding sink in by using actual
stories and things related to dance so
they're not just words and definitions a
few caveats I'm gonna focus today on
standard Ruby because memory allocation
and garbage collection are really
enormous topics and they work slightly
differently in every programming
language and I also want to add that
there are a lot of memory or performance
tweaks they can
made by looking at things like database
queries or other things but we're not
gonna dive into those today
so let's get started as I mentioned we
were first alerted to this problem when
we started getting those web server
errors first we saw request timeout
errors so request timeouts happen when
an HTTP request takes longer than 30
seconds to create so the request is
still going and it may actually complete
but it means that the request that was
sent to the Heroku router via Dinos took
longer than 30 seconds to complete and
we also got memory quota exceeded errors
and this means that the Dino needs more
memory than it has you'll see this sort
of error in your lugs so likening this
to Angelina Ballerina to take the base
of the story as plot Angelina is so
focused on dancing and loves dancing so
much that she never remembers to do
anything else that she needs to she
never takes a break and is late for
school
requests timeouts and just simply can't
remember the things that she needs to
memory quota exceeded see where we're
going here so her situation like ours
leads to all sorts of errors in not
being able to remember what she's
supposed to be doing next and then
running out of time to do things so this
is what that webserver graph looks like
these are those little boxes we had a
few processes running in different
threads because splitting portions into
threads and background jobs helped solve
some of our earlier performance issues
this is sort of where you can tell what
those threads are we saw that we were
running out of memory through those
colored boxes now we can't get very far
into understanding memory and the tools
without understanding some basic terms
about memory so we'll start with some
basics memory allocation is like asking
for a box give me a place to start doing
stuff with and then memory is the box
which can be he per stack we'll continue
talking about that and memory usage is
actually putting stuff into the box so
that has Ruby use memory well Ruby uses
memory by retaining objects there are
two types of
memory stack and heap stack is memory
that's temporary so it's like local
variables that are created when you call
a specific function so angelina's
focused on dancing once she's enrolled
in dance school that's her heap and
there are all sorts of things that she
needs to remember wallet dance school
and that heap we'll get into that next
but the one-off tasks are like being on
the stack clean her room help make
dinner do a chore she can remember this
for a short period of time do it and
then forget about it
heap is unmanaged memory where you're
saying please just give me a blob of
memory so that whenever I call a
function there's already memory there
malloc is mentioned in a lot of garbage
collection and memory talks malloc is a
function in C it's the function that
actually allocates a certain number of
bytes and puts a pointer at the first
bite of allocated space there's also
callek free realloc functions and malloc
like literally stands for memory
allocation Angelina in dance school uses
her heap memory it's all this space
allocated for dance specific knowledge
but whether she's learning about a turn
a new ballet position or a dance step
she's made the space in her mind to
dedicate to learning and remembering all
things related to dance and then within
that heap there is the Ruby heap and
there's the Machine heap so Machine heap
is this big blob and then Ruby heap is a
portion of that machine heat that's
focused just on the Ruby related
functions
so within Angelina's dance memory there
might be a small portion that's
dedicated to ballet
so her overall dance memory might also
contain information about tap jazz folk
etc but she also has this like little
ballet heap specific for ballet since
there's a heap within the heap there is
a chunk or page allocated inside that
chunk is a length list and each node in
the linked list is a slot and each slot
is a Ruby object so the heap is ballet
the chunk is like ballet feet positions
the list is a list of bel
positions and each slot as an actual
ballet position so in ballet these are
like first position second position
third position - sixth position the list
is what's called a free list which means
that the program looks to find the first
open slot and that becomes the Ruby
object
so once the slot is filled the pointer
which is just the thing that says like
hey look at me over here moves to the
next free space and this is called bump
pointer allocation when all the slots
are filled that's a full page when
there's a full page a new page is
allocated and that new page is called an
Eden page because there are available
slots the objects filling up each of
these slots are called retained objects
memory usage grows in Ruby programs as
more objects are retained and as more of
those slots fill up so here you see that
there are now retained objects and
eleven of those slots and new memory is
allocated for what might come so as
Angelina learns more steps more turns
more dance terms she can't remember
everything she needs to prioritize what
she remembers and what she no longer
needs to remember when the garbage
collector runs the allocated objects can
be collected and thrown away so that you
can reuse those slots so now we're going
to get into a garbage collection is to
further understand the difference
between memory usage and memory
allocation we're going to take a brief
detour into garbage collection garbage
collection is a type of automatic memory
management that makes a program seem
like it has infinite memory by
reclaiming objects that are no longer in
use so there are languages that have
automatic memory management or garbage
collections and ones that don't so for
example Ruby or Python are both
automatic memory management languages
you don't need to think about memory and
allocation of objects or implementing
garbage collection in order to free up
memory manually the language just does
that for you but in a language like C
for example there's no
automatic memory management so part of
what you need to do while programming is
also worry about asking for memory
freeing up old memory and only accessing
reading and writing where you're allowed
to garbage collection was written about
first in 1960 by John McCarthy in his
paper recursive functions of symbolic
expressions and their computations by
Machine part 1 the best part of this
paper is that there is no part to just
part one this paper talks about lists
and some of the interesting aspects
about lists and one of these things
that's discussed is this idea of the
program automatically being able to
allocate and free memory his idea
developed into what we call garbage
collection today we talked about some
garbage collection related words before
when just sort of going through how
memory works in Ruby but I'm going to
mention them again because also I think
that some words and concepts are easily
understood or understood in different
ways when you talk about them through
different lenses so I'm gonna mention
them again through the lens of this
garbage collection process so garbage
collection has two parts the allocation
and the collection think of the
allocation as the steps to perform the
dance and the collection is the person
actually doing the dance the allocation
refers to the heap or stack so remember
the heap is a data structure that you
have access to and you can allocate and
deallocate objects from the heap
additionally as opposed to stack memory
this allocation and de-allocation can
happen in any order a heap can be an
object graph which is a directed graph
where the nodes or heap objects and the
directed edges are references to the
heap objects in the slots we're going to
break this down further so the route is
Angelina or the source of the dance the
nodes or positions or turns and the
references or choreography that get you
from one node to the next the stack are
specific allocations based on methods or
functions that are called stack
allocation focuses on four
lastin first-out a location on the stack
where a record let's say Angelina clean
your room is pushed onto the system
stack when the process is called and
gets popped off once the process returns
garbage collectors have three main
responsibilities they allocate memory
for new objects they identify which
objects are garbage and no longer being
used and finally they reclaim that
memory by freeing those no longer used
objects so we're talking about the heap
and looking at allocation and
identification that's the allocation
piece of garbage collection and the
steps so the steps of the dance whereas
the collect part is obviously related to
the collection and doing the dance and
then sort of forgetting about the moves
as we finished them so some of this will
sound a little familiar a granule is the
smallest unit of allocation that exists
like the idea that there are positions
in dance a chunk is a large group of
granules like an allocation chunk a
chunk or all of the ballet positions
that exists and chunks have lists and
these lists are linked lists of nodes
and this is like a list of ballet
positions and each specific position is
a node each slot as an object and each
node on the list is a slot in each slot
has an R value which gives you
information about that node and our
value is the R object and the r string
with the art class this slide is stolen
from pat Shaughnessy because it's a
really good diagram of this hole our
value sort of thing each node or slot
being a ballet position so it has a
value which is an object of string in a
class so that would be like the string
first position let's say the class of
position and the object which is
position 1 equals position Don now this
slot also has a reference or pointer
remember we talked about the bump
pointer before an address so objects on
a heap or talked about by using their
address and objects can refer to each
other
and these slots are pages which are
contiguous on the heap which basically
means that they're just together on the
heap the total number of pages that a
program needs to keep in memory to avoid
increasing how long it takes a program
to run by more than a specific
percentage is the program footprint so a
program in this case might be a
choreographed dance the dance has lots
of different steps and turns and you
need to know belly fundamentals like the
positions as well as a lot of other
information all of that information that
you need to know about this particular
dance is the dances footprint these
pages and slots are also referred to as
the object space and in conjunction with
this idea of allocation and collection
garbage collectors have a mutator and a
collector
so the mutator is the code that produces
the garbage so if there was infinite
memory then you know any collector would
be great because it would never have any
garbage that needs to be collected but
that's not our scenario our programs
fill up memory and create objects when
it executes it mutates the heap so think
of the mutator as the dance steps let's
say you do a certain type of turn at the
beginning and then you never do that
turn again for the rest of the dance the
dance and that turn are part of the
mutator and then they can be forgotten
and collected by the collector so now
we're going to look into the collector
portion a little bit the collector first
identifies which pieces of garbage are
ready to be taken out by tracing through
the edges or references from the route
and anything that it doesn't connect to
is garbage so it does this by looking at
the references from the route so roots
or areas of the heap that can be reached
without asking other areas of the heap
how to reach them
so here Angelina Angelina is our route
there are entry points into the heap so
in Ruby for example the object class is
a route object in the heap the collector
finds the unmarked nodes and sweeps them
away in
one type of garbage collection algorithm
and the collector is triggered based on
thresholds thresholds are the number of
slots so once we're out of slots and we
need more garbage collection is
triggered there are a few different
garbage collection algorithms or
approaches I'm going to briefly go into
four of them and then we're gonna drill
down into Ruby's garbage collector so
the four approaches are copying mark and
compact reference counting and mark and
sweep so first we're gonna talk about
reference counting reference counting
means that every time you refer to an
area of memory and the heap you keep
track of how many times you've referred
to it so you're keeping count an object
is only live if the number of references
to it is greater than zero so you can
easily say great all of these
allocations are zero and that means
they're garbage and can be collected the
biggest problem with reference counting
is that if you have two objects that
refer to each other the reference count
will always be greater than zero and
therefore they won't be able to be
garbage collected ever well that's good
because it's incremental so you don't
need to stop everything to figure out
what's going on but it's bad because
there's a lot of overhead to constantly
keeping this count and keeping a
reference in real life deferred
reference counting is usually used which
can lead to floating garbage require
application pauses etc objective-c and
python use reference counting type of
garbage collection so next to copying
the copying collector reduces the size
of the available heap it divides the
heap into two semi spaces the from space
and the to space the objects fill up the
from space once you've figured out which
are the live objects and which are the
garbage objects the live objects are
copied from the from space to the to
space and whereas in the from space all
of the garbage objects were interspersed
in that heap semi space when they're
copied over they're all put together and
compacted and then the pointer moves to
the end of those live objects
demonstrating or more
locations can be made then the from
space and the to space are swaps so the
from space is where the live objects are
and the to space is ready to be copied
into again when needed the biggest issue
you see with the copying collector is
memory fragmentation so you can have a
from space that looks sort of like this
and it looks like you have places to put
memory so it doesn't look like we need
to do any copying yet but as we see
there are actually no spaces that are
big enough to fit this object that needs
to be placed finally is the is
mark-and-sweep with two variations
regular American sweep and mark sweep
and compact so in this type of garbage
collection the collector goes through
all the objects and marks everything
that's still live where there are still
related pointers then it sweeps and then
for mark sweep and compact it rearranges
the heap and compacts those objects for
just mark and sweep it does the same
steps but just without compacting them
at the edge here when the slots or nodes
in the linked list are used up then in
rubies stop the world marking happens
and what that means is that the entire
application pauses and goes through all
of the references and marks anything
that's live which means there's still
reference from that root node and
everything else is deemed to be garbage
the whole object graph is traversed in
order to do this this type of stop the
world collection happens in a lot of
different garbage collection approaches
so our link lists
nodes are each of the nodes here and
once they're filled we need to stop the
world where we go through that whole
tree we see the root is Angelina and
everything referenced from the root
relates to ballet in our case but these
three nodes are related to other forms
of dance and are no longer referenced by
the root and so they're garbage so going
back to our Angelina example we can
think about Angelina doing a dance she's
performing a ballet and so she can't
remember everything about all different
kinds of dances she knows that this is a
ballet dance
so she referenced so she's referencing
in her mind ballet positions turns and
moves as she performs but she doesn't
need to know anything about tap or jazz
those aren't really referenced at all so
they can be collected so that she can
really focus on the ballet moves that
she needs to there's no overhead there's
no overhead every time an action or
mutation happens like in reference
counting but the deallocation of memory
is delayed which means that the
application needs to pause to stop the
world for a longer period of time when
garbage collection and the allocation of
memory does happen so ruby uses
mark-and-sweep garbage collection in
production sort of in reality most
garbage collector is used in production
are a mix of different garbage
collection algorithms and optimizations
so ruby actually uses mark-and-sweep
with generational and incremental
garbage collection which incorporates
pieces of reference counseling type
functionality into the process alright
let's get into that so we're gonna jump
into generational garbage collection so
once you've completed the normal mark
and sweep steps the objects that remain
get promoted to the next generation so
let's look at Angelina let's say
Angelina is learning a new dance
she learns a bunch of steps there's a
turn there's a leap she wants to do some
fusion tap move as Angelina practices
she decides that she wants to cut out
all of the leaves those leaps can be
garbage collected because she's no
longer using them and therefore the tap
knock as well but she wants to keep all
the pirouettes those turns on the other
side so a pirouette stick around and get
promoted to the next generation which is
like version 2 as she continues to
choreograph her dance generational
garbage collection operates under the
under the hypothesis that most things
die young so you might try a bunch of
things out but only a few of them stick
around so here we're continuing to
choreograph this dance we have some
steps already in place and we have some
new steps we've chosen to only connect
one of these steps to the
and to the dance steps that we already
have each time you collect the garbage
the stuff that sticks around goes into
the next generation when you do the next
round of garbage collection you don't
need to revisit all of that stuff that's
in the old generation you can just say
okay that's there it's live it's staying
live I don't worry about it you only
need to go through the newest generation
to mark-and-sweep from there so in this
generation this node and this node would
be marked and we don't have to look at
any of the others because they're
already in the older generation this
saves time because we're not looking at
every node every single time you're
simply looking at the nodes in the
newest generation but one possible side
effect of this is that you have a is
that if you have a node in an older
generation and a new object gets
allocated from an object in the older
generation into the newer generation
because we don't check anything in the
older generation this new node in the
new generation will be assumed to be
garbage and will be freed because that
reference isn't checked so this leap
that we've added into our routine won't
be remembered because it's a reference
from an old object so in order to make
sure that that new object is discovered
we need to put a write barrier in place
a write barrier make sure that the
reference goes into the remembered set
through barriers the mutator can inform
the collector of what's happening
it basically says hey you need to make
sure to look at me even though I'm in
the older generation and you wouldn't
think to do so so when a garbage
collector does its thing it'll look at
everything in the new generation plus
everything in the remembrance said one
other aspect is that while generational
garbage collection reduces the average
pause time because you're not traversing
that whole object graph it does
introduce a sort of permutation overhead
which pulls in some of those aspects of
reference counseling that we mentioned
earlier
finally there's incremental garbage
collection generational garbage
collection optimizes mark-and-sweep and
incremental garbage collection optimizes
generational garbage collection so
incremental garbage collection happens
through the tricolor marking algorithm
the tricolor marking algorithm says that
objects are white black or gray when
their weight they'll be collected when
they're grey they're referenced from the
root but we haven't looked at anything
that they reference and when they're
black they have no references pointing
to anything but they are referenced from
the root so you trace through the gray
objects referenced from the root you
make those black you change the colors
of anything that the new grey nodes
reference and you make those grey and
then for any gray objects you mark them
and then you take any newly great
objects and make Villas black and there
are none here so then you can sweep
sweep away the white objects alright in
more complex systems you do this process
until you sweep away all of the white
objects then once an object is black
you're no longer looking at what it
references so the benefit of this is
that you can stop it at any time you can
do a little bit at a time you don't have
to completely stop the world for a long
period of time to do everything related
to garbage collection all at once you
can stop then do a little bit let the
program continue to stop again etc but
there's a problem here if a black object
references a new white object it could
unknowingly be freed because for all
black objects as we said you're no
longer looking at what they reference so
here again you install a right barrier
so that it goes into that remember it
set and isn't forgotten about when doing
it dance you can't just have turn after
turn quick move after quick move you
need to have higher and lower places for
activity in order to catch your breath
and actually make it through the whole
routine again one interesting piece of
Ruby is that it's not compacting so you
can't rearrange or compact
Ruby objects so if pages have open slots
or holes in them you can actually
prohibit how much memory or how many
pages you can actually destroy and how
much memory can be recollected this is
like if you could never have dancers
change position in a routine so you have
five dancers and two of them walk
offstage you can't readjust the
spotlight because you still sort of have
dancers all over the place
ideally they would move together so that
the spacing looks right again but Ruby
doesn't allow us to do that you can't
free slots well reference to it still
exists like if you're on a loop for
example so if you make a request and
then the system is processing it as its
processing the request it's it's
creating all these objects you need to
retain all the objects all the request
is going if you run out of memory the
garbage collector will run but if
there's still a reference to those
objects then they can't be collected and
you can't free up any of that memory and
that's when we get allocated memory
rails apps are a collection of retained
memory which are the things that will
sort of hold on to forever or for a long
while plus allocated memory which goes
up and down and that combination of
allocated objects plus retained objects
is memory usage once the process
finishes and a response is delivered the
garbage collector can run again and free
some of those objects so all this
explanation helps us look at the tools
that we needed to check out in order to
improve how memory is being allocated
how objects were being created and then
freed in order to allow enough space for
the process to run how many people here
know the movie sneakers okay if you
haven't seen it you should definitely
check it out it's an awesome movie from
the 90s when there's there's a scene
where they're trying to learn more about
someone and they go through all of his
garbage talking about how going through
someone's garbage is the best way to get
to know about get to know them so
earlier we talked about how Ruby uses
memory filling up these pages and slots
with retained objects the GC library the
Ruby GC library is going through the
garbage of your app to really get to
know it it has a ton of tools that can
help you determine what's going on along
the way so for example GC stat has a ton
of different options one option is total
freed up jects so this is useful when
you're creating lots of objects that
when you when you're creating lots of
objects and you want to see if those
objects are being released in order to
make room for new objects by running GC
stat total free defore and after a
method you can see how that's working or
if it's working at all
this can help determine if your garbage
collection process isn't as efficient
because there are objects being used
that are still being referenced
somewhere and therefore can't be garbage
collected so we're going to dive into GC
stat super quickly and all the
information it gives so this is all of
the information that you get I'm not
going to talk about each one of these
because that would be an entire talk but
I will highlight a few
so heap-allocated pages or how many
pages are available for use in the heap
they could be filled or empty whatever
it's just the total number of pages so
this is like a dance routine you're
doing you might not take up all the time
but it's how much time you have for
dance moves
heaps sorted length is the actual size
of the heap
so this is the total number of slots and
all of the pages even if a page is free
or use the length still stays the same
so each Ruby heap page has four hundred
and eight slots the size of each slot is
40 bytes so each page can hold about 16
kilobytes if we're thinking about this
routine that we're doing though and the
length of the song this is how many
moves are in the song you can change
some of the choreography in the middle
and you still have the ability to
choreograph those moves heap available
slots is how many total available slots
there are in all of those pages it's
like the total number of dance moves
that can fit into a specific dance
routine heap live slots are how many
slots are filled with live objects that
can't be garbage collected so let's say
in our dance we have a prop like a
fundamental top Hatters
you can't get rid of the prop entirely
until you're done with all of the dance
moves that use that prop heap live slots
would be how many dance moves use that
prop and then heap free slots or how
many available slots are left to fill
before running out of memory so this is
what's left you have a certain amount of
the song where you need to use the prop
and then the rest of the song is free
but there's still a finite amount of
time before the end of the song heap
final slots is how many slots have
finalizar has attached to them but where
the finalizar hasn't run yet so final
answers are basically run once the
collector has determined that it's
collecting the garbage and it runs when
the garbage is collected and an object
is freed or D allocated so this means
that these slots are currently busy or
live but they're about to be freed so if
you're in the middle of doing a sequence
of turns once these turns are over and
you don't do them again you can forget
about them this turn is like one heap
final slide total allocated objects is
how many objects there are to use so as
we work on our dance we add in turns we
may change some of those turns this
would be like how many total turns can
be worked into the dance total freed
objects' or how many of the objects have
been D allocated and therefore their
memory is available again for the
current process so we're choreographing
we have a total of 8 turns that we can
do we decided to get rid of two of them
so the total freed is 2 as we continue
to change steps this will be the total
number of objects that we sort of
removed from the dance so here our total
fruit objects is 3 for the time being
there are a bunch more GC set options
but I wanted to just highlight those you
can run GC set in a rails console or IRB
and you can look for a specific
measurement by using a command like this
GC stat count using this library they're
also GC profilers that gives you access
in your code to all the garbage
collection information so you would do
something like this and when you ask for
GC report you get back this it tells you
things like how long it took to run the
total size of the heap the total number
of
in the heap etc another powerful tool is
the object space library object space
has a lot of different options in it as
well so for example object space that
each each object will go through every
object that's currently allocated it'll
show you the total number of objects by
class that are live you can also pass in
a specific class to only find out that
information for specific class of
objects remember that object space is
basically another way of saying heap and
the object space keeps track of all the
references to all of the live Ruby
objects the object space library lets
you traverse all these living objects
and supports finalizes as well so just a
few examples that you can do in IRB or
in the console object space dock count
objects gives you the total number of
live objects the total number of free
objects and then the total number of
objects in each class so like the total
number of string objects hash objects
etc and so if object space is the heap
and the heap is a dance with dance steps
then asking in the object space to count
the objects it's like asking what dance
moves do we have here how many leaps how
many turns etc if you're working with
rails there are also these four really
awesome gems that I wanted to talk about
but of course did not have enough time
to get into but you should definitely
check them out so there's a lot to read
here there's a lot that I didn't go into
today
for example garbage collection is
actually a much more complex topic and
like I said before it differs based on
what programming language you're working
in additionally there are more aspects
to memory including database
optimization and all sorts of other
components that we also didn't discuss
today you can find the resources that I
use in putting this talk together on my
website as well as some additional ones
that are really good to dive into and
I'll tweet out a link to these slides
after as well thank you and I want to
say a specific thank you to a few people
who helped me throughout this talk
mainly mike bernstein krista
since Steve Reichert and Jason Roloffs
for fact-checking providing extra
explanations and being really great
people to chat with throughout putting
together this talk and thank you
[Applause]